the company was called based on the
first product due to mobile we were just
about converting desktop sites to mobile
sites
[Music]
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders thank you for having me
so great to have you i'm so excited to
chat because
i'm i you're going to tell me one of the
most fascinating stories i think that
one could tell in the entrepreneurship
space which is
identifying an emerging market out of
the garage in mountain view
with one of your best friends but i'm
not going to give away the whole story
itai
how did duda come about yeah
so it came about in uh late 2008
and me and as you mentioned a very good
friend that i know since
actually since high school uh
we we were both here in palo alto
working back then for sap
and uh we were you know for for a very
long time we were trying to come up
we always knew we wanted to do something
together we just didn't know
what it would be and we probably had a
thousand different ideas
that we thought about over over the
years and shut them all down
you know for different reasons and then
um kind of walking uh the actual idea
for duda didn't come up in
in the garage it actually came up while
walking around in on university ave in
palo alto
i know you live in palo alto so very
very close
and going into the absolute that has a
thing that has a bar in it so
everybody knows so uh walking to the
apple store
this is the same apple store that steve
jobs also used to live right
right in the neighborhood and he used to
visit that same store as well
and looking at that first version of the
iphone the first version of the iphone
came out in 2007
and we were playing around it in in 2008
and
you know it just dawned on us for the
first time that the entire internet was
you know moving into this device but who
knew i mean
yeah iphones came up they were great
they were tiny
and you know the real first you know
real good touch interface
how did you realize that wow yes
internet is moving to mobile because
because yeah we were both engineers and
we played with all the technologies you
know there were phones
before that uh there were blackberries
and there were nokias and
we were programming with stuff like whap
and
it it it just was not the experience it
was a very different experience than
going to your desktop and getting the
full experience
of the browser and suddenly that same
experience that you would get on a
desktop
was for the first time available on on
us on a
small smartphone and we we knew that
they they got it they they did something
right and we were looking
back then at you know some of the first
companies that took advantage of that
phone and created their dedicated
you know mobile sites like amazon you
know did m.amazon.com
and m.ebay.com and so on and you just
had a different
they also created a very dedicated
experience for the mobile phone
for all these mobile users and we're
looking at around and we understood
you know to to build something like
amazon was able to do for a mobile phone
you needed resources you needed like
specific skill set you needed
budgets know-how and it's all different
it's a whole different learning
experience right like the whole user
experience and the whole
i mean the whole adaptation you have to
make as an engineer i know like as a web
developer myself
building for the phone is not the same
as
now okay amazon can afford that right
and so can ebay but what about uh
the dentist or the the owner of the
pizzeria
or you know take all you know 200
million small businesses out there
clearly they don't have the budget to
know how
and the resources to do that right that
was kind of when
the epiphany of we're going to help the
little guy
be able to create a store very easily
very simply
so that they can actually compete
against the bigger guys in the market so
the first product we launched was called
back then the company was called
based on the first product due to mobile
we were just
about converting desktop sites to mobile
sites
and wow and we we started working on
that in very late 2008.
that's that's just incredible so you're
working on that about a year and a half
after the first iphone comes out and
really the world gets introduced to
mobile and
and a fun user experience that is
actually you know comparable
in the number in the amount of things
you can do to the computer i'm gonna
give a small spoiler 10 years later
duda has over 800 000 websites that it's
hosting
that is correct how do you even i mean
looking back you know in 2008 you're
sitting there in the garage in mountain
view at this beautiful picturesque
moment
do you do you even under like think that
you're going to get to 800 000 websites
built with duda
well you know as a it's it always sounds
like an overnight success but it's an
overnight success of 10 years with a lot
of ups and downs in
in in between and you know i remember
in 2009 you know we kind of we built the
first prototype and we were
back to that same street on university
ave kind of knocking on small business
stores and asking them do you want a
mobile site so
really starting one by one and getting
these small
at least to validate the product and
that there was the real need
um and it was also remember 2008 was a
pretty
uh 2009 was a pretty tough time yeah we
went money for this now right yeah we
went to investors nobody
wanted to invest back then really nobody
saw
the need it was really tough until
uh until we had a really great break in
in early 2010 when we
signed we did a deal with att uh back
then 18t interactive
part of atnt that saw the opportunity
and really wanted the technology in
order to sell
to their small business customers wow
that's incredible
duda what's duda so
dude is uh so the the the product
evolved
uh on the product the name the name the
name
the name of course the the dude you know
the
rudowski have you seen the movie i have
not but i read your bio and
i know the quote up in the quote anyways
okay next time you have to do a prep
before you do
a call with me but yeah so it's
see the movie i'm sure you'll enjoy it
i'm actually i'll send it to you
um so there's you know a really
many people know it it's a cult movie uh
the main character is called the dude
played by jeff bridges
and uh both amir and i and my co-founder
we are big fans of that movie we we
watched i probably watched it you know
tens of times you know 10 20 times
and uh like a girlfriend screams at me
when i watch
a movie more than once so she would have
promoted she's gonna have a harder time
watching this
yeah so we started watching it back you
know back in college
uh in in israel and um you know it
became a
part of the culture you know if you come
into our offices
you'll see you know different although
all the conference rooms have names
really there's like you know the ringer
urban achiever
the rug room it's a really funny movie
it's
uh i think you might yeah i think you
wrote it your favorite quote from the
movie is about a rug that ties the whole
room together
okay dude you have to see the movie i
can't uh
yeah but yeah it's it's all the whole
story starts with uh
you know the main characters uh rug
gets stolen and uh you know
i love it itai you you transition you
you're you're
very very successful with duda and now
you're you're also
very big in in venture capital you're a
part of the j ventures fund
which i which i'm very happy to be part
part of as well part of
a you know tlv partners mentor at upwest
labs you invested in trip actions
right pretty early on yeah yeah i uh in
in the seed round uh wow okay
the cto is a very close friend i
invested in ela
like back then they said travel
companies something i said
dude i'm i'm investing in you like
whatever
and turned out to be a very successful
company
you know you know i i just had a really
great a great chat with dovie which we
released
recently and one of the things we were
talking about was impact investing and
his whole
you know investment thesis and i'd love
to know because you're not a full-time
investor right you're a part-time
investor
you're doing it you can see from your
background that you're doing it out of
fun and you're just as much a mentor
as you are an investor so talk to me a
little bit about this strategy of yours
and how you collaborate with companies
yeah so it's really
uh i do it as a side hobby i'm not i
wouldn't consider myself a real uh
investor it's uh just when there's like
an interesting opportunity
and unfortunately i'm so busy in my
day-to-day work that
i would hope 800 000 websites so please
be busy
yes uh so kind of i would say most of my
eggs are in that basket
but once in a while uh if there's like
uh
something someone i believe in some
opportunity
uh usually tied to people it's really
tight tight to people that i know
uh then i'll you know here and there
i don't do it a lot but uh it is fun
when when i do
i love it and it's time to i mainly
enjoy
you know working with them sharing my
experience
uh you know discussing challenges
and uh yeah so i think that's that's
really the fun part
italian i want to talk about emerging
markets it's very rare
somebody who identified an emerging
market was right
rode the wave went through the
challenges you know raising capital
in 2009 and trying to get customers i
mean
i i can i you know i didn't do it myself
but i can
i i can see why would be very difficult
i wanna i want to be in your position i
want one day to be able to sit down and
think of a new market
and really ride that wave and and know
that yes i i
i was right and i made a dent because
you did you made a huge
impact on the on the internet world and
and small and smb's presence online
what are some of your you know insights
looking back on identifying emerging
markets
and riding that wave yeah i think it's
uh
the first uh it's important to find
a real pain point uh and
you know where there's enough people who
share that pain point and where you
think you can come up with a very
unique offering to solve to solve that
pain
and i think we came we we found that
in uh you know in late 2008 and 2000
kind of
with the first product right i think you
all
you always need to come back to it you
know this whole
product market fit right this is
basically what i'm uh
you know building a product that fits
with uh
with a certain pain in the market right
the fact that you found it doesn't
guarantee that it will
last forever and this is kind of where
i think over the years we've kind of we
had our ups and then we had our downs
and now we're like a couple of years of
another like found it again you i think
this is the the role of
you know of the entrepreneur of the
founder really to make sure that that
product market fit uh you know uh
is maintained but it's very hard to get
product market fit
on the get go when you're looking at an
emerging market right because you don't
they they don't necessarily understand
they don't have iphones yet necessarily
they don't understand that
this is where things are headed so it's
kind of a chicken and the egg right
are you letting the market take over
first and then you're gonna go and try
your luck
or are you gonna try and be on top of
the wave and and how do you get your
first customers on board
yeah i think uh you know like it
it's the hardest to educate a market
about something that they don't know
they need but i think you know we we
when we came out with the with the idea
for
for mobile websites back then you know
we validated the idea we we we put some
ads on the internet and
because if there's a pain then people
are looking for ways to resolve it they
might
not know what the solution is but you
know
we bought some uh adwords campaigns
around
you know build mobile website you know
create mobile website
and the first customers we actually used
our own tech
the technology was not ready to hand it
over we used our own technology to build
sites almost like an
agency as a service so just to validate
that the technology that we built was
good enough
it took probably you know a year like
that until it
got to a place where we could hand it
over to other people
to build uh websites on behalf of uh
small businesses or or give it directly
to small businesses to do it themselves
right what were some of the most unique
challenges that you faced as the ceo
you're starting out in a garage with an
idea
you're you know you're running from door
to door to try and sell this and all of
a sudden you're growing and you're
scaling and
success comes and investors come how
like what do you tell yourself who are
who do you go to what what are some of
the things that you experience
yeah okay yeah that's uh there's a lot
packed in that question
a lot um well we have five minutes so
i'm sure we can get over
everything right okay yeah i think uh
you know the
what i would say is that i think when
when you're growing and and you're on to
something and scaling
you know growth solves a lot of problems
it creates problems but it also you know
when there's growth
when you see growth then investors see
growth and they want to invest
and you know i think that's that that's
easier to solve it's kind of uh you know
rich fans problems there are problems
that come with growth but those are
solvable
i think the the the harder challenges
is when you know when you're not seeing
you know when it's not that clear or
when
markets change and that happened to us
like we were
you know if i go to 2014 so we were just
doing
i think of 2010 to 2000
something like that we were just selling
mobile sites we we got to
you know we got a huge amount of
customers
uh buying from us mobile sites we had
partnerships with
godaddy and google and opentable and all
that
and suddenly uh it wasn't as suddenly
but
we we identified a risk because the the
the web was moving to kind of responsive
web design and we were only
a mobile site and we were looking at
this and we're saying
wow like we're at a risky place because
you know there's suddenly there's
tablets and there's mobiles and
desktop and people have browsers on
their watches and in their cars
nobody wants to build a site for every
different device and kind of responsive
web design rows is the right way
to do it you build it once it runs
everywhere
so cutting a chart we understood we
needed to build for that
we need to develop our our product in
that direction we can't we re
we built another product basically the
the
product that you see today which is our
responsive website builder
is our second product that's the pivoted
product from the restaurant so we had to
pivot to another product
and luckily that we did it because the
you know the decline started happening
into our first product
and if we hadn't recognized what the
shift in the market we we basically lost
product market fit so we had to re
rebuild a new product to fit what the
market
actually wanted and i think those were
the tough years of rebuilding that
product and relaunching on another
product
uh 2014 to 2016 were two
you know two pretty tough years we even
went through a little bit of layoffs uh
back then wow
and then eventually with you know
catching kind of the wave again with a
new product
we're now you know uh five six years
later
uh obviously it was we
we kind of obviously we made the right
decision and the company has grown
significantly since then but that was
like uh
almost a sudden death moment there where
you know you're
kind of you know and and you know that
there's quite a few companies
over their history that kind of missed
that right they had the product market
fit
if we were talking about phones
blackberry nokia i was just about to
they were a rubber company did you know
that no i didn't i didn't know that
but so they pivoted once well to phones
and to electronics
they didn't complete the pivot though
it's it's hard it's hard to do it and
maybe for a next
you know next conversation we can talk
about what it takes to
to pivot and the challenges with that it
sounds like to me
it takes a lot of bravery and it takes a
lot of confidence in yourself and the
team to be able to say listen
we might not be doing the right thing
right now we did two years ago but
things are changing
we're and we're we're again going to
have to understand our market and to be
better again
yeah now now take that think of like at
like a nokia blackberry where you have
thousands of people selling
product a and you need to tell these
people well these
this product that you're selling that's
bringing billions of dollars
forget about it that's history you need
to be selling product b you understand
how difficult it is to transition the
problem is that you can't wait
for the product to stop selling you have
to know ahead of time in advance
so while you're starting the decline
you'll already start working on the
other thing
and that's the hardest thing because
then they're coming and saying to you
like what are you talking about we're
still selling
we're making billions of dollars which
which marketer would give you real
estate on
like the home page to put a new product
when
you know everybody's like everybody's
buying the the old product but this is
the this is the role of the entrepreneur
the founders to really understand the
dynamics in the market
have the vision and persuade everybody
else to to follow them
itai what are you passionate about
what am i passionate about uh you know i
i love working with people i love
working with the team i love
you know the challenges every stage in
the company
you know this is why it's it's interest
it's always stays interesting because
the challenge is to get to the first
million dollars of revenue
is different than the challenges to get
to the 10 million
which is completely different than the
challenges to get to 50 million
so i think it just keeps keeps it very
very interesting
and you learn a lot you know it's kind
of the best uh
best education that you can get is
actually to try to
to build a business and to scale a
business and i think that's something
that i really enjoy
i love it itai right before we leave i
want to thank you again for this
great inspiration and such a remarkable
story i love
emerging markets i love you know sitting
down and trying to identify what's
happening and where is the world moving
ever since i i started with j ventures
as well
i've that's that's i mean that's i think
the biggest gift that that a new
young entrepreneur can get is to really
try and understand
what are the dynamics how do markets
work how do entrepreneurs work
and italia before we leave i need three
words that best describe you
yeah i think i i always
manage to keep it you know to keep calm
to be cool you know things
things get thrown at you from the left
it looks very
cool and uh and i think you need to
you need to know to cope with it so i
think people will if you ask people will
tell you that
you know it doesn't matter you know it's
one day could be good news the next day
could be bad news
you need to kind of plow through it and
uh
you know continue to move on and uh and
improve
i love it i'm definitely reaching back
for some advice when i have my own
startup so so look out for that email
and i thank you for your time and
inspiration yeah thank you for having me
was fun
take care bye